juan obtuvo una muestra aleatoria de
datos sobre cuánto tiempo les tomo a 24
estudiantes terminar un juego de
reacción y un juego de memoria
cronometrados cuando tuvo una relación
lineal positiva entre los tiempos de
cada tarea
a continuación se muestra un ejemplo de
los datos recabados
estos son los estadísticos recabados del
tiempo de reacción y del tiempo de
memoria de los juegos después la
computadora cálculo una regresión usando
los datos recabados supón que se cumplen
todas las condiciones para la inferencia
calcula el estadístico de prueba que
debe usarse para probar la hipótesis
nula de que la pendiente de la población
en realidad es 0 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de responder a esta pregunta
antes que nada debemos asegurarnos de
que comprendemos lo que está pasando
aquí primero analicemos la población es
posible que existan algunas relaciones
lineales reales en la población en
teoría tenemos el tiempo de reacción en
el eje x y en el eje y tenemos el tiempo
de memoria si pudiéramos graficar todos
los datos posibles que podría ser una
cantidad casi infinita de datos o lo que
sería muy difícil de graficar
si lo hiciéramos y resultara que si hay
una relación lineal positiva con estos
datos y que se vea así podríamos
describir esa recta de regresión como ye
sombrero igual a un parámetro real de la
población que sería la ordenada de
origen le llamamos alfa más otro
parámetro real de la población que será
la pendiente de esta recta de regresión
y que llamamos beta x x ahora no sabemos
cuál es esta relación lineal entre el
tiempo de reacción y el tiempo de
memoria pero podemos tratar de estimar
la y eso es justo lo que juan quiere
hacer así que juan toma una muestra de
24 datos la cual es mucho más fácil de
analizar y se puede visualizar en un
diagrama de dispersión como este tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 puntos los
cuales ingresamos a un programa de
computadora y este nos entrega una recta
de regresión que trata de minimizar el
cuadrado de la distancia de todos estos
puntos y vamos a suponer que la recta
regresión se ve así esta recta podemos
describirla como un estadístico el cual
es una estimación del parámetro real de
la ordenada al origen más otra
estimación de la pendiente real de esta
recta de regresión esta vez es un
estadístico que trata de estimar el
parámetro real de beta al ingresar estos
datos a la computadora obtuvimos estos
valores como los parámetros de la recta
de regresión a es igual al coeficiente
constante y b es igual al coeficiente de
reacción que nos dice cuál es el cambio
esperado en y por cada cambio
incremental en la reacción o cambio en x
esta es nuestra estimación de la
pendiente de la recta de regresión se
pueden imaginar que cada que tomamos una
muestra diferente podemos obtener una
estimación diferente de esto cuando
realizamos estadística inferencial
establecemos hipótesis
la hipótesis nula y la hipótesis
alternativa la hipótesis nula siempre es
aquella que indica que no hay cambio
alguno y al trabajar con regresiones
esto significa que aún cuando
sospechamos o vemos en los datos una
relación lineal positiva para la
hipótesis nula suponemos que no hay una
regla
lineal aquí la hipótesis nula es que la
pendiente real de la recta de regresión
lineal real es igual a cero y la
hipótesis nula es que la recta de
regresión se ve así el valor de ye es
independiente del valor de x si
sospechamos que si hay una relación
lineal positiva entonces la hipótesis
alternativa es que el valor de la
pendiente es mayor que 0 o si
sospechamos que hay relación lineal
positiva o negativa la hipótesis nula
será que la pendiente es distinta de 0
en el enunciado nos dicen que juan
sospecha que hay una relación lineal
positiva así que esta es su hipótesis
alternativa lo que debemos hacer y que
hemos visto muchas veces con
anterioridad para probar la hipótesis
nula es que debemos encontrar un
estadístico de prueba que esté asociado
con el estadístico para ver que
obtuvimos realmente lo ideal sería tomar
esta vez y restarle la beta que
suponemos en la hipótesis nula tomamos
la pendiente de la recta de regresión
obtenida y le restamos la pendiente que
suponemos de la hipótesis nula esto lo
dividimos entre la desviación estándar
de la
muestral de la pendiente de la recta de
regresión si hacemos esto sería
apropiado usar un estadístico z el
problema es que no conocemos la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral pero podemos estimar la podemos
calcular la pendiente que obtuvimos de
la recta de regresión lineal muestral
menos la pendiente que suponemos en la
hipótesis nula que será igual a cero y
podemos calcular el error estándar de la
distribución muestral de hecho vemos que
la computadora lo hizo por nosotros esto
es una estimación de esto conocemos
todos estos números pero si usamos una
estimación de la desviación estándar de
la distribución muestral es apropiado
usar un estadístico t como vimos cuando
estudiamos estadísticos inferencial es
para medias
dicho esto pausa en el vídeo y piensen a
qué será igual esto pues va a ser igual
a la pendiente de la recta de regresión
muestral que sabemos vale 14.686 menos
el parámetro real de la población que
suponemos de la pendiente para la recta
de regresión real que suponemos es 0
dividimos esto entre el error estándar
qué es 13.329 si hacemos una prueba
unilateral tomamos el estadístico t y
pensamos en los grados de libertad para
poder calcular el valor p cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado así
o más alto dt igual a cero ese será
nuestro valor p y si resulta estar por
debajo de cierto umbral y decimos que
eso es poco probable entonces rechazamos
la hipótesis nula y se sugiere la
alternativa pero no nos piden hacer todo
esto solamente nos piden calcular un
estadístico de prueba apropiado que es
lo que hicimos aquí nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo